Eh,
Eh, Eh, Youtube space? No.
Eh, Eh, Eh,
Eh,
Eh, eh. Me. What, why did,
again,
I need to stay in the unit,
Eh,
eh.
[inaudible]
number a hundred document that
my joy.
What type of content you,
Eh,
eh?
How'd you meet a,
I showed the movie and stuff.
Eh?
Why did I say stop?
[inaudible] [inaudible]
[inaudible] [inaudible] [inaudible]
go to this,
Eh, my eyes. [inaudible]
which the court, your name is, you
do the space. Nobody knew, or even
[inaudible] [inaudible]
[inaudible] [inaudible] more,
Eh,
Eh, Eh, Eh,
Eh, no personality shooting.
Get
[inaudible] [inaudible]
[inaudible] [inaudible] eh,
acting courtyard now.
[inaudible] [inaudible]
[inaudible] [inaudible] mister
McCay. Cool. Yeah, so he got
[inaudible] [inaudible]
[inaudible] [inaudible] Coco
such,
Eh,
she can go to mother
[inaudible] [inaudible]
or [inaudible] [inaudible]
[inaudible] [inaudible] [inaudible] there,
eh?
[inaudible] [inaudible]
[inaudible] [inaudible] squishy,
squishy.
The mass.
Yeah.
Yeah,
yeah.
Well,
thank you both.
Hey
guys can work on,
or just saying
[inaudible] [inaudible]
[inaudible] just say one day
I wasn't there.
[inaudible] [inaudible]
[inaudible] [inaudible] the rope cannula.
Eh,
so you can ask your queen no cover
no more.
Yup.
[inaudible] [inaudible]
[inaudible] [inaudible] see what
the majority of our so called
[inaudible] [inaudible]
[inaudible] [inaudible] show to stay.
[inaudible]
the Eh,
talk when you do say no.
[inaudible]. [inaudible]
[inaudible] [inaudible]
[inaudible] [inaudible] don't,
don't, don't, don't Nugeo Nonaka Day.
[inaudible] [inaudible]
[inaudible] [inaudible] [inaudible]
you will not sort of communication.
Do you know what, Eh,
Eh, Eh, eh?
[inaudible] [inaudible]
[inaudible] [inaudible] [inaudible]
so one another that don't,
don't, don't, don't quote
me. Not they could use,
given the kids are gonna know that
you need, don't, don't, don't, don't,
don't do an icon on the
uterus. None there, eh.
[inaudible] [inaudible]
[inaudible] call you in one day,
which, Gosh, I started giving them one
day. Never comes in. And I told them,
isn't it
okay?
I know.
[inaudible] [inaudible]
[inaudible] [inaudible] [inaudible]
demo now than you are
Tutsi. Then she bit today,
she didn't go to Missouri,
so we're not that unique.
Okay,
awesome. I love them. You got the
[inaudible] [inaudible] there,
eh, Japan machine. Good.
And mother,
and you're not [inaudible] no more salad.
They don't know what
you're headed towards.
You then you're not going to
part of a part or whatever.
You're not going to call
the clinic to achieve. Um,
so don't focus on the
[inaudible] [inaudible]
[inaudible] [inaudible] senior shoe.
They are I data.
So you [inaudible] you had
more juvenile mass when you say
[inaudible] [inaudible]
[inaudible] Mazda Deca ISD
that I could do anymore.
Kanji data, external
[inaudible] [inaudible]
[inaudible] [inaudible] they're
pretty good data. Get the door
[inaudible] [inaudible] oh.
[inaudible] [inaudible]
[inaudible] [inaudible] call other
bigger that the core Arabic that you
[inaudible] [inaudible]
[inaudible] your [inaudible].
I know you have a conduit to you anymore.
She starts to know [inaudible] [inaudible]
[inaudible] [inaudible]
[inaudible] [inaudible] [inaudible]
[inaudible] they don't know why.
[inaudible] the mall.
So one of the
[inaudible] [inaudible]
[inaudible] [inaudible] [inaudible]
[inaudible] [inaudible] [inaudible] I
take her at [inaudible] the water and then
you can get Eric and I told us there
none day we should right there.
[inaudible] [inaudible]
[inaudible] none there.
Yup, buddy. [inaudible] now you've got
[inaudible] [inaudible]
[inaudible] they took the hunter
so today,
Eh,
Jeff would have got a coaching Tokyo
[inaudible] [inaudible]
[inaudible] [inaudible] [inaudible] well,
so when you put us
[inaudible] [inaudible]
[inaudible] [inaudible] the year.
So you're not talking
to anyone series called
[inaudible] [inaudible]
[inaudible] more, Eh, Tony?
I don't know.
15 [inaudible] [inaudible]
[inaudible] [inaudible]
[inaudible] [inaudible] eh,
Eh, Eh, Eh, Eh, Eh,
Eh, you made us, Eh, Eh,
Eh,
eh.
[inaudible] [inaudible]
[inaudible] [inaudible] Jamie Oliver.
More breaking ground.
No more
[inaudible] [inaudible]
[inaudible] [inaudible] [inaudible]
you don't think you call it
[inaudible]? [inaudible]
[inaudible] [inaudible]
[inaudible] my mass.
None of the MCOs in the contract.
I'm wondering [inaudible] [inaudible]
[inaudible] [inaudible]
[inaudible] isn't that the key?
Yours?
I'm the Yerba
[inaudible] [inaudible]
[inaudible]
that Eh,
Eh,
Jack Chateau
[inaudible] [inaudible]
[inaudible] [inaudible] [inaudible] eh,
every academic, I don't know what it's
going on. A community got screwed at under
[inaudible] [inaudible]
[inaudible] or [inaudible] machine.
[inaudible] can you get [inaudible]
[inaudible] [inaudible] [inaudible]
[inaudible] [inaudible] standard on that.
They don't know about different
countries. The mass. The Ma
[inaudible] [inaudible] [inaudible]
[inaudible] [inaudible] Geesh.
Then we'll murdered eh? No, nobody. Qubit.
You guys still
yes,
I know.
So [inaudible] not
[inaudible]. [inaudible]
[inaudible] [inaudible]
[inaudible] [inaudible] to
know [inaudible] negative
[inaudible] none of that.
Eh?
Tony [inaudible] who is [inaudible]?
Yes.
The Corner
[inaudible] [inaudible]
[inaudible] [inaudible] I know.
Eh?
No neon or eh,
she ain't [inaudible] [inaudible]
[inaudible] [inaudible]
[inaudible] [inaudible] [inaudible]
this the episode on complex,
not the tissue on this.
That's all you
[inaudible] [inaudible]
[inaudible] [inaudible] [inaudible]
so when you [inaudible] that,
was
it always the machine you thought?
Who you DNA so it or separate
to shut the [inaudible].
Yeah.
[inaudible] then machine there
we got to the soldier who us.
Now what does that, you know, community.
So they taught it, show it unit together.
The [inaudible] with us is,
we say that your result there,
nay.
I didn't want that notch members demo.
We just learn about what does
[inaudible] [inaudible] [inaudible] non
[inaudible] archive yours or more equity
in some what color if you need to.
Tomo.
Thank you.